at what point are you guys like at this
point politics what role does politics
play in your life at 18 years of going
into boot camp about all Republicans was
racist I thought all white people's
racist yeah um I was raised to be a
Democrat
my mom always uh taught us to see look
Democrats are for blacks Republicans or
for whites you know she taught me that
from as young as I can remember like
five six seven years old I remember was
watching the debate and then she always
up and down she couldn't stand a
republican yeah what was the reasoning
because she linked Republicans to racism
is that kind of she was very naive when
it came to politics mommy had no idea
that Jim Crow was by democrats she had
no idea that the KKK was started by the
Democrats she had no idea my mom was a
good woman but she ain't no [ __ ] about
politics yeah that's a lot of ours still
right I mean if you look at a lot of our
you know who raises us they don't they
don't sit there and go so what event
caused you guys to get a little bit more
into it and get interested was it this
insurance job that you guys had where
right I was saying it's my older brother
um he was a republican he used to put
things in my ear but I just thought he
was Uncle Tom at the time yeah you know
I just I think over time as you like
live your life and you have experience
of uh other people other than that look
like you you start to develop like you
know what I have control over my life if
I make good decisions I would go for it
has nothing to do with my skin color and
I think we just both saw that over time
yeah I remember when we first came
across uh I didn't know the difference
between a liberal and a conservative I
came across Ben Shapiro right I remember
he was on Pierce Morgan show that was
going out guns yeah yeah it was NRA
Second Amendment yeah so I was a batshit
crazy a little bit uh you know so I'm
like looking at Ben Shapiro and I was
like oh man that white supremacist he's
got an answer for everything you know
and then I found out that he was Jewish
it's like wait a minute
how can a white supremacist be Jewish
those two don't go together yeah so I
started listening then after I watched
Ben Shapiro even though I I hated
everything he said everything he said
made sense then I came across Larry
Elder started looking at Larry and then
and then he came across um Mark Levin
Mark Levin you on the radio yeah Keith
would just listen to him because he was
always talking [ __ ] about Obama we just
thought he was race
but the boy you listen to him it's like
dude's starting to make sense yeah you
know now who's introducing you to this
stuff is it your older brother or are
you just jumping across it YouTube I got
you yeah and are you guys living
together at this time after the Marines
uh no we're not living together at the
time but I remember I started seeing
Kevin said man look at this new Ben
Shapiro
he's killing this black guy over here
and uh it's just common sense really
yeah I think conservatism to see in
conservatism is all it is is common
sense yeah if you just sit and listen to
both sides and just be objective and
listen to what both sides are offering I
literally do not understand how anybody
could be a Democrat these days Jesus I
mean you got you got women competing
against men you got they pushing all
this stuff on kids with the drag queens
and hysterectomies for girls yeah before
they go into people because they want to
be a man I mean this [ __ ] is this is a
freeing stuff it should not be being
pushed mainstream like it is I think the
breaking point for us is um I vote for
Obama's first term because I I thought
you know I didn't really know I just
voted from because he was black at least
be honest about it yeah I'm being honest
about it but um he was the eye-opening
after Obama and I started listening to
both sides I hated Obama so much I
actually voted for Mitt Romney yeah they
take a net yeah whom Obama could flip to
Mid Romney yeah he was the only option
wow how did that happen yeah think about
that when Obama ran think about this it
was it was Mitt Romney and John McCain
and oh wait it was mokay and McCain in
12 years that's correct that was the
Republican option I think uh I think I
I'm not too much into conspiracy
theorists it's like they almost set
Obama up to be president yeah
they almost set him up to be president
as a one-term senator
what do you mean set them up yeah like
they planned it like they wanted a black
president yeah it's like they're both
liberal I mean like who's both liberal
uh McCain I mean they're Republicans but
they're liberal the way they vote the
way they uh their views it's liberal
like Mitt Romney is not a republican you
know what I mean McCain he's a
republican but no he's really not a uh
uh conservative it's like that was your
only option if you didn't want to say
Obama well don't these people are called
rhinos right Republicans and names only
wouldn't said the problem with you know
we can kind of talk Democrats
Republicans what what conservatives
these days but the the contingency where
you're talking about Liz Cheney or Adam
kinzinger are the people who are not you
know Republicans these are traditionally
what Republicans are now it's Maga right
so there's this kind of infighting
within that I don't even think that they
would say that Maga is not traditional
Republican so how do you process that I
just think there's a bunch of dis
information Maga I mean Trump is not the
Republican Party correct you're Trump is
not the Republican party yeah correct
Republican party now are conservatives
uh people believe in conservatism the
Constitution that's what the Republican
party is it's not Maga it's not Trump
trump galvanized the constitutionalists
who are on the right but he is not the
Republican party that's just propaganda
that's all that's that's all that you
actually think that's bigger than that
to discredit the Republican Party sure
they are but do you actually think when
you Define conservatism the first thing
you go to is the Constitution because
that's not where I go whatsoever I don't
think I don't think 99 out of 100
Americans could tell you what the hell
the Constitution says left right or
something the same way I'm saying
freedom of speech freedom to carry a
weapon yeah yeah trading to a family
freedom to go to work I mean just basic
rights that we have under the
Constitution and over this last pandemic
they took all that away from us even the
Republicans initially shut everything
down but over time the Republicans was
the party say hey we're hiding from a
virus yeah this is stupid you can't hide
you can't run from a virus it's time to
go back to work and live our lives but
the only people that remained it shut
everything down and want to hide from it
was the Democrats yeah Republicans just
believe in Freedom let me live my life
yeah and Democrats think they know how
to uh to uh live everybody's life for
them I'm not for that that's the
Republican party of my eyes also
Republicans just want to be left alone
Democrats wants to be in everybody's
life it seems like to me so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]